notre invité politique ce matin c'est
clémentine autain bonjour je veux être
avec nous député la france insoumise et
la seine saint denis en étant 100
pendant 20 minutes lors d'une interview
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et de ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjour bonjour bonjour et la
question évidemment de début c'est
autour de ces discussions discussions
qui se sont poursuivies hier jusque tard
à entre les insoumis les écologistes et
qui reprennent ce matin et qu'ils
reprennent avec les socialistes et les
communistes mais aucun accord n'a été
conclu qu'est ce qui bloque d'abord
c'est long c'est long de se reparler de
faire le point sur les ambitions
programmatique et ce que l'on peut
partager c'est ça va pas de soi donc il
faut comprendre qu'on a besoin de ce
temps ce temps d'explication ce temps de
précision et d'essayer d'avoir un accord
de nature politique 1 on l'a dit depuis
le début nous on veut pas une simple
répartition ou une simple voyez ce que
je veux dire
voilà c'est vraiment une union politique
puisque l'enjeu c'est de gouverner le
pays à partir du mois de juin donc il
faut savoir sur quelle base on gouverne
et donc quelles propositions politiques
nous faisons anciens on va parler du
fond et mais c'est le fond qui blogue
c'est des questions ce sont des
questions programmatiques comme c'est la
répartition des circonscriptions qui
pose problème ou les deux par définition
les deux vous imaginez bien que on
travaille en parallèle sur la
répartition des circonscriptions et
c'est pas simple je vais pas vous cacher
les choses évidemment ça n'est pas
simple donc ça suppose beaucoup
d'allers-retours beaucoup de discussions
de d'argumentation et donc voilà
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui puisque nous
sommes le 3 mai anniversaire du front
populaire nous réussirons à l'issue de
cette journée d'avoir un grand grand
accord qui permette je crois de nous
hisser à la hauteur de l'histoire et des
de l'urgence sociale et écologique que
rencontre la france aujourd'hui ce temps
d'explication une précision que vous
évoquez vous n'avez pas eu avant la
présidentielle vous avez vous négocié
pendant des mois qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce
qui change non vous n'êtes pas parlé du
tout finalement en vrai je ne peux pas
dire qu'on se soit beaucoup parler
en revanche ce qu'ils avaient c'était
impossible de le faire avant la
présidentielle pourquoi c'est possible
permettez moi juste de revenir sur ce
que vous soulignez pendant la
présidentielle ce sont même des noms
d'oiseaux assez désagréable que nous
avons entendues notamment à l'encontre
de jean 10 00 discussions 0 le changeant
de nom franchement dire que voilà
l'ambiance était était sympathique et
chaleureuse donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé s'est passé d'abord que les
français ont tranché et ce qu'ils ont
tranché c'est entre deux grandes
orientations d'une orientation
d'accommodement avec les politiques
néolibérales avec le productivisme ou
alors une politique de rupture tel que
nous la proposons les français avaient
déjà tranché en 2017 puisque jean luc
mélenchon avait recueilli 19 % des
suffrages et le parti socialiste avec
les verts faisait six bons ces gens
allaient discuter après parce qu'on
sortait du quinquennat aux langues non
mais on sortait du cac à la face qu'à
l'époque il a été reproché à jean luc
mélenchon de ne pas avoir rassemblé à ce
moment là j'en vends vous reconnaissez
que ça a été une erreur finalement je
pense que la discussion était plus
compliquée à ce moment là je dis pas
qu'on n'aurait pas dû peut-être
davantage
voilà les mains tendues et engagé
engager la discussion mais ce que je
sais aussi c'est qu'à ce moment là on
sortait du quinquennat hollande donc on
n'était pas tout à fait dans la même
dans la même situation voilà il ya eu
cinq ans et les français ont un nouveau
trancher et renforcer leur position qui
souffriront c'est bien une gauche de
rupture qui peut remettre sur pieds
l'espérance qui peut mobiliser un
électorat qui est à la fois écoeuré de
la politique est désespéré par la gauche
notamment en raison de ceux de ce
quinquennat de cette expérience récente
de la pseudo gauche qui en fait a mené
une politique de droite au pouvoir donc
on a cette histoire là mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que ce qui nous arrive
vient de loin vient de loin en réalité
ça prend sa source à mon sens en 2005
avec le traité constitutionnel européen
ou à ce moment là la dynamique du non de
gauche qui ne veut plus de ce grand
marché libre et non faussée qui n'en
peut plus non plus de cette technocratie
technocratie qui gouvernent contre le
peuple ça qui se passe et bien
à partir de 2005 je pense qu'on commence
à écrire une autre histoire avec les
collectifs antilibéraux puis le front de
gauche qui fait un score à deux chiffres
déjà avec jean luc mélenchon en 2012
puis ensuite la france insoumise voyez
ce que j'ai c'est qu'il ya un élan dans
la société qui est porteur de radicalité
au pluriel et que c'est bien ce camp-là
de la gauche qui peut permettre de
redonner des couleurs à notre véritable
rapprochement aujourd'hui donc 17 ans
après ce fameux traité 2005 est
exactement mais vous savez quand vous
regardez la grande histoire vous savez
bien que
voilà des choses se font il faut
comprendre les racines et ce qui se joue
et je crois qu'olivier fort comme julien
bayou dans cette séquence prennent aussi
la mesure de ce que je suis en train de
vous dire de ce que les français ont
tranché dans les yeux alors justement ce
qui semble bloquée avec les socialistes
notamment c'est la question de l'union
européenne olivier faur l'a dit lui il
ne veut pas du mot désobéissance sourire
dans le compromis fin dans le dans
l'accord est ce que vous êtes prêts
justement à faire ce compromis est
enlevé ce mot désobéissance au traité
laissons les négociateurs négocier donc
je ne vais pas vous dire quel est le
point de l'entente puisque le point
d'entente étant en discussion après je
veux dire ce qu'ils que ça signifie
derrière désobéir parce que ce que je
sais c'est dans ces négociations parfois
il ya des incompréhensions des préjugés
on pense que l'autre et pensa voyez ce
que j'ai en fait c'est quand on commence
à décortiquer à démêler qu'on finit par
se dire ben en fait on n'est pas si pas
d'accord que ce qu'on pensait voyez ce
que je veux dire donc si on désobéit à
fossa qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire derrière
ça ce qu'on veut dire derrière ça c'est
que si par exemple en france on veut
créer un pôle public de l'énergie et que
les traités européens nous disent non il
faut ouvrir à la concurrence
eh bien nous on pense qu' il faut faire
ce pôle parce que les français nous ont
donné un mandat pour cela alors on le
fera c'est ça on appliquera pas les
normes des traités on appliquera la
politique conformément à la souveraineté
française populaire français sauf que
vous savez que les mots ensemble surtout
dans des accords comme ça à l'acte mais
du coup vous vous expliquez voilà ce que
vous voulez mais le mot désobéissance il
faut leur âge je suis en train je suis
en train de vous répondre que ce sont
aux négociateurs de dire comment les
socialistes et les insoumis peuvent
s'entendre sur le vocabulaire mais ce
sur quoi nous ne bougerons pas c'est sur
l'idée que je viens de vous dire c'est à
dire concrètement nous estimons qu'au si
l'union européenne nous empêchent de
mener des politiques de progrès social
écologique alors nous n'appliquerons pas
ce ces impositions européenne voilà
c'est on a bien compris sur cette
question exercise est vrai qu on bougera
pas moi je veux bien qu'on discute des
mots mais ce qui est sûr c'est que sur
ce point mais ce que nous demande si
j'ai bien compris les socialistes c'est
aussi de savoir si ce que nous voulons
c'est demain un freak site voilà les
d'ailleurs avec europe ecologie les
verts c'est aussi ça la discussion ça a
été ça et nous avons écrit noir sur
blanc que l'enjeu n'était pas une sortie
immédiate de l'union européenne et de la
monnaie il m'aidait à mixer pas non mais
même immédiate ça c'est pas c'est pas de
notre jeu n'est pas la sortie de l'union
tout court voilà même avec le long terme
c'est moi là on est en expansion vers
des jeux le rapport à l'épée non c'est
pas notre objectif n'est pas celui là
notre objectif est de pouvoir appliquer
notre politique sans contrainte
européenne qui nous amènerait vers des
régressions à la et de mener bien sûr
comme on l'a toujours dit la bataille
vous savez dans non de gauche au début
tu vois je vous raconte ça mais c'est ça
avoir un tout le débat public c'était en
fait le sujet c'est pour ou contre
l'europe c'était ça et des termes du
débat qu'on voulait nous imposer c'était
ça et c'est à partir du moment où nous
avons réussi à mettre sur la table que
l'enjeu c'était pas ça c'était pour ou
contre cette europe là et c'est à ce
moment là que le nom gauche a créé cette
dynamique parce que parce qu'au fond
c'est pas qu'on ne veut pas leur moi je
pense que les politiques menées
actuellement c'est elle qui tue l'europe
c'est ça qui tuent leurs hommes et ça
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut sera long mais mes
mails mâcon dit que cette europe là
n'est pas parfaite inclus à des mais la
manière n'est pas parfaite et ça ne va
pas parce que le cours néolibérale est
une catastrophe voyez il ya un monde et
manuel macron c'est très bien de quel
côté il est puisque il incarne ce pôle
qui développe toujours plus cette
extrême centre et ce néolibéralisme qui
produisent la régression des inégalités
autre point compliquées par rapport aux
négociations en cours l'ukraine les
latitudes ville krell le ps et europe
ecologie les verts sont favorables à la
poursuite de livraison d'armes à
l'ukraine et qu'elle est quelle est
votre position et comment comment est ce
que vous allez pouvoir vous mettre
d'accord sur ces points alors la
question est notamment posée à jean luc
mélenchon s'il était premier ministre
parce que vous savez qu'il ya une
répartition aussi des rôles le président
de la république et le premier ministre
ce serait une situation un peu
particulière parce que le président a
quand même beaucoup de pouvoirs en
matière de politique sinon j'ai
habitations donc jean luc mélenchon le
dis très clairement et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs c'est pas un point dur des
négociations ni à la marée verte pas
dans la loi la nuit avec les socialistes
puisque jean luc mélenchon dit très
clairement que le président de la
république dispose aujourd'hui
d'informations dont nous ne disposons
pas pour décider s'il envoie ou non des
armes que d'ailleurs lui seul sait ce
qu'il en moi et que donc c'est une
question qui est beaucoup plus complexe
et épineuse que ce qu'on veut bien dire
et nous leur disons je vous le redis
très très tranquillement nous avons
immédiatement apporter notre soutien aux
ukrainiens face à l'agression de
vladimir poutine donc il ya moins un
point qui ne fait pas débat j'irai au
sein dé gauche contrairement à ce qu'on
a entendu dans la campagne
présidentielle qui sont mis sur la
question des arts vous avez un petit peu
changé de position au bénin c'est
maintenant la jugeant mauvaise d'un
régionales c'était quand même con
belligérance et le cje termes qu'avait
employés jean luc mélenchon est une
notion politique voilà et je pense que
jean luc mélenchon vous le redire est ce
qu'on ce que nous disons c'est que nous
voulons emmener le camp de la paix voilà
et que la question est de ne pas être
comme belligérants parce que entrée en
guerre contre la russie implique quand
même
il faut envoyer des armes y envoyer des
habous vous ne lisiez opposera pas je
vous dis que c'est un débat complexe et
pas c'est pas je vous dis que c'est un
débat complexe que nous n'avons pas
toutes les informations et et que jean
luc mélenchon voilà discutera avec le
président de la république que les
choses ne sont pas figées mais par
contre il sera du côté de la paix en
train de chercher une solution
diplomatique sur l'attitude vis-à-vis
des sanctions l'union européenne prépare
un sixième train de sanctions avec un
embargo total éventuelles sur le gaz et
le pétrole russe vous comment est-ce que
vous positionner par rapport à ça alors
on est pour élever le niveau des
sanctions l'a toujours dit mais aussi
pour protéger les français des effets
écoutez là c'est pas ce que je veux dire
c'est que là tout de suite on n'a pas
forcément toutes les clés pour répondre
à la question que vous posez voilà et
que ce qui compte c'est en juin comment
le vent sera la situation quelles seront
nos marges de manoeuvre et ce sera une
discussion entre le premier ministre et
le président de la république sur la
réforme des retraites
premier oui oui oui alors pour vous
après l'accord ce sera 60 ans pour tous
ou uniquement pour les métiers
difficiles et avec un départ à taux
plein à quel âge alors nous sommes à ça
dépend d habiter en fait un le départ à
taux plein c'est le nombre d'annuités en
tout genre 10 40 annuités et le départ à
60 ans alors c'est ça le l'objectif que
nous nous fixons la discussion qui pour
le coup a lieu en particulier avec les
socialistes elle est celle du rythme
c'est à dire en combien de temps on est
capable de revenir à la retraite à 60
ans avec ses 40 c 40 annuités je crois
que ça fait partie de la discussion qui
a lieu en ce moment avec avec les
socialistes mais nous tiendrons bon ça
c'est clair que pour nous la retraite à
60 ans c'est un marqueur
avec 40 annuités c'est à dire pour les
gens qui rentrent sur le marché du
travail à 25 ans par exemple à partir à
la retraite à 60 ans oui oui mais ce qui
est déjà le cas aujourd'hui c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui
mais quand c'est pas 60 ans pour tout le
monde quel que soit votre carrière non
c'est pas le départ à 60 ans pour tout
le monde quels cas le départ à 60 ans
mais tout le monde quel que soit le
careï ce qu'il faut c'est les 40
annuités passion et les le taux plein ça
vous ne changez pas il a 67 ans
aujourd'hui le taux plein âge à la nana
na na na hey ça on va voir on va avoir
des tonnes de discussion là dessus parce
que c'est très technique après en moi
j'ai fait toute la toux le débat sur la
réforme des retraites je peux vous dire
que c'est un niveau de technicité qui
est quand même très élevé donc il faut
il ya plein de mécanismes donc déjà il
faut des mécanismes protecteurs pour la
pénibilité donc par exemple quand vous
dites vous partez en vacances sur la
pénibilité le départ à 60 ans fin soit
partir à 60 ans il peut y avoir aussi
plein de métiers de pénibilité qui font
que même si on n'a pas les 40 annuités
on part à 60 ans ça vous faisiez les 40
annuités donc on reste globalement sur
cette logique mais ensuite il faut
regarder dans le détail donc quand vous
êtes pénibilité il faut pouvoir partir à
60 ans à taux plein à taux plein
j'entends bien à taux plein globalement
des métiers vous le savez bien où il est
possible de partir des métiers qui sont
moins pénibles physiquement où il est
possible de partir plus tard les
simplement d'une résine la république
lui propose 65 ans mais globalement avec
vos partenaires socialistes et
écologistes vous êtes vous êtes d'accord
sur la rassure le sur la méthode à
adopter la retraite et est ce que c'est
un point de discussion un point
problématique entre vous réjouit disais
tout à l'heure oui ça a été un point de
discussion c'est le toujours ou souvent
je pense que ça l'est encore avec les
socialistes je suis pas si
aujourd'hui
je t'aime peut-être qu hier soir ça a
été ça a été réglé
mais je ne sais pas voilà je vous joue
pas je vous dis les choses très vite ça
fait partie des discussions
d'aujourd'hui c'est ce trio rihaoui
voilà je crois que il y a eu un accord
sur l'objectif du départ à la retraite à
60 ans mais c'est faux on avance vers
sète cet horizon est ce que dans les
airs et raisonnable dans les autres
points bloquants il ya la question de la
bannière du nom de la bannière avec les
écologistes a été actée nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale est ce
que ça ça convient à tout le monde ou
est ce que là il ya des discussions
autour de ça mais je ne suis pas dans
les négociations d'hier soir donc je
peux pas vous répondre on imagine que
vous avez quelques heures je crois
savoir que nous avons trouvé là pour le
coup dans l'accord avec europe ecologie
les verts une bannière qui peut faire
consensus je le crois le parti radical
de gauche lui refuse tout rapprochement
avec vous avec la france insoumise il
parle jeune site d'arrangement d'europe
écologie les verts du parti socialistes
et des communistes vecteur du nain
sincérité qui nourrit l'extrême droite
qu'est ce que vous réponde à ça il ya un
espèce de concert vous avez remarqué un
depuis quelques jours
c'est assez amusant sur tous les
plateaux vous le trouvez aussi bien dans
la bouche des représentants du président
de la république l'extrême droite un
certain nombre d'éditorialistes un seul
coup très affolé très agressif donc moi
j'appelle au calme
je vois que le parti radical de gauche
rendent dans ce concert donc je
comprends que ça suscite un peu de
panique parce qu'on est en train
d'écrire un scénario qui n'était pas
prévu donc je
sacré pour voir la panique bien sûr il
ya la panique il ya des inquiétudes
il ya de la peur jusqu'au sommet de
l'état vous avez vu quand même que
président de la république n'a toujours
pas nommé son premier ministre ça fait
quand même dix jours qu'il était lui
donc il ya quelque chose qui visiblement
ne tourne pas tout à fait à ma mort avec
je le crois sincèrement je le crois oui
il doit chercher une équation qui permet
de nous contrer et visiblement il est du
mal c'est pas facile vous pensez que
donc du coup il a qu'il attend que vous
ayez conclu un accord voir sur quelles
bases pour désigner son premier où sa
première ministre reconnaissait que
c'est une hypothèse qu'on ne peut pas
exclure est ce le la question moi aussi
je me pose la question je vous dis
franchement je pose la
rejoindre votre accord est ce que vous
savez s'il ya des discussions à ce que
vous souhaitez écouter on applaudit on a
voulu rencontrer du npa au parti
socialiste donc si on a voulu rencontrer
tout le monde sait qu'on voulait un
accord avec tout le monde alors on
parlait du npa c'est parce qu'on en
parle moins est ce que c'est parce
qu'elle est un accord qui est difficile
à conclure je crois que l'accord là
aussi il ya des négociations je sais pas
où elles vont aboutir je ne peux pas
vous dire à cette heure voilà mais notre
souhait est de faire langue de force le
plus large possible le mode de scrutin
aux législatives il faut que 12 et demi
pour cent des inscrits pour être au
second tour c'est à dire qu'avec une
abstention mettons de 50% il va falloir
25% des voix off est deuxième au premier
voilà ça veut dire qu'il y aura
quasiment que des duels est ce que ça
vous inquiète c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle vous craignez une alliance
entre la république en marche et les
républicains pour contrer vos candidats
au second tour non mais moi j'aime pas
tellement réfléchi en termes de mécano
de ce type quel va être le mécano qui
nous permet de ce qu'on cherche c'est
l'adhésion des français voilà ce qu'on
veut c'est gagner par adhésion des
français on à 105 circonscriptions dans
lequel nous sommes arrivés en tête en
tête de tous les autres candidats et
avec la configuration qu'on est en train
de mettre en mouvement je pense qu'on
peut vraiment être en dynamique premiers
ou seconds dans un maximum de
circonscription gagnée cette majorité
c'est ça l'enjeu donc je ne crois pas à
voile à des raisonnements par contre lac
l'enjeu de la participation ça c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet et pas
simplement pour les douze ennemis c'est
un sujet parce que pour gagner notamment
dans les circonscriptions populaire nous
avons besoin que ceux qui ont trouvé le
chemin des urnes à la présidentielle ne
rentre pas chez eux désespéré et le fait
que jean luc mélenchon est donné comme
objectif d'être premier ministre c'est
aussi ce qui réveille les sports avec
cette idée de troisième tour et d'un
seul coup on croyait qu'on avait perdu
mais non en fait on a encore la
possibilité d'empêcher cinq années de
casse sociale avec emmanuel macron et de
mépris vous pensez vraiment que ça peut
marcher parce que l'enjeu essentiel le
vrai enjeu de ces législatives c'est la
participation c'est comment on fait pour
amener les gens aux urnes on sait
pertinemment qu après la présidentielle
le taux reste l'abstention est énorme la
dernière fois c'était plus de 50%
d'abstention premier puis au second tour
ce qu on va on va pas vers le même
scénario sachant qu'il ya cette semaine
entre la présidentielle et législatives
comment vous faites pour ramener les
gens exactement ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est à dire que je pense que
l'acte posé par jean luc mélenchon est
celui qui peut permettre de mobiliser
parce qu'il donne un objectif de
victoire donc ce souhait ce dont le
récit à la fois le l'union à gauche plus
jean luc mélenchon premier ministre ça
c'est vous pensez que c'est quelque
chose oui il peut marquer les esprits
imprimés oui je crois vraiment je pense
que ce sont les en effet les deux étapes
alors vous dites l'union à gauche je
veux insister ce magnon de gauche n'ont
pas de voix les écologistes aussi et je
vais ainsi insisté sur le caractère neuf
c'est à dire que si on donne à penser
qu'on a fait
une union des gauches classique on
recommence avec la bouche coeur etc je
pense qu'on est à côté de l'histoire ce
qu'on essaye de faire c'est à partir de
la méthode qui a été celle de l'union
populaire d'élargir et de rassembler
plus encore mais c'est pas simplement un
accord avec des appareils politiques
c'est dans la société que nous cherchons
l'énergie la force de construire cette
majorité parce que ce qui s'est passé à
la présidentielle c'est que nous avons
réveillé des catégories de population
qui ne voulait plus aller voter qu'ils
ne croyaient plus dans la politique je
pense que no no no no capacité à être
majoritaires elles dépendent de sa de
cet éveil évidemment pour qu'il y ait
cet éveil il vaut mieux avoir du
rassemblement aussi dans les forces
politiques mais ça ne suffit pas et donc
on a une méthode pour ça et qui est une
méthode qui vise à mobiliser dans la
société
bien sûr monsieur sur la question des
investitures on va évidemment préfère
les 500 façon 17 mais vous savez qu'elle
nage aurez du mal à vous répondre il ya
notamment une investiture qui fait débat
c'est celle de ta boîte à l'euro à
bosser vous avez des idées elle faisait
pas que elle fait aussi débat au sein
des autres partis de gauche qui est vous
soutiennent a priori avec lesquels vous
allez conclure un accord ta boite je le
rappelle condamné pour injure non tu as
raison non ils ont engagé une année par
un non choix s'il était condamné pour
avoir insulté une policière
d'années il a été condamné en première
instance et merci maman est-ce que son
investiture est ce que vous soutenez son
investiture oui bien sûr je soutiens son
investiture bien sûr je soutiens sont
exigeants jean luc mélenchon juste quand
eric zemmour s'est présenté à la
présidentielle il a dit qu'il était
opposé à ce que des personnes condamnées
pour incitation à la haine raciale
puisse se présenter en mairie celui-ci
passe avec ce qui vaut pour eric zemmour
ça vaut
d'abord ça vaut pas pour uriner moore du
tout puisque le voyez bien sûr les
pattos il explique que pétain a sauvé
des juifs et ça dérange pas grand monde
quand même hein au regard de la violence
de ce qu'ils racontent donc ta aboaf est
un militant et quartiers populaires un
journaliste indépendant qui joua
rappelle un permis de faire sortir la
sphère benalla donc c'est pas n'importe
qui tabasse mais pas que oui mais pas
que mais qu'est ce qu'on décide mais pas
qu'eux mais quoi mais il ya aussi pour
midi mais non dit ce qu'il a dit
qu'est-ce qui la cantine une policière
quand il traite une policière d'arabe de
service pour vous c'est pas un problème
mais bien sûr que ce ne sont pas des
mots polis et comme il faudrait les dire
c'est pas bien voilà d'accord mais avec
tout ce qu'on entend aujourd'hui sur les
plateaux télé je vous assure que c'est
pas ce qui me choque le plus quand on a
un président de la république est
capable de parler aux français en disant
qu'il ya ceux qui réussissent et ceux
qui ne sont rien ça c'est d'une violence
inouïe et voyez il n'est pas condamné
bon donc moi je je je ne dis pas que
tous les propos de ta aboaf jolie
partage c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet
c'est que je dis que si on veut
régénérer la politique si on veut
l'ouvrir si on veut que ce soit pas
toujours les mêmes profils qu'ils soient
en responsabilité qui représente le
peuple alors il faut qu'on ait la
capacité à nous ouvrir à des
personnalités comme ta aboaf qui a
encore une fois fait partie aussi de
cette génération qui ne mâche pas ses
mots en effet et qui est capable de
mener des batailles politiques fortes
contre le racisme parce que franchement
condamné et aboaf qui est un militant
antiraciste pour incitation à la haine
raciste quand même pas la même chose que
zemmour peut pas mettre tout ça sur le
même plan ça n'a pas de sens ou alors
vraiment on a perdu la tête comprenez
non je vous redis ce qu'elle a dit jean
luc mélenchon qui voulut qui vaut les
moyens de condamner contre comprenez
comprenez que comprenait la folie du
truc c'est à dire que eric zemmour
condamné pour elle insiste on voit bien
le sujet c'est tout c'est toute sa
colonne vertébrale qui propose un projet
xénophobe taabo a fait un militant
antiraciste qui vient des quartiers
populaires alors on peut dire ces mots
là c'était pas les bons mots qu'il
fallait dire sur un plateau de télé mais
vous pouvez pas à cause de ces trois
mots expliqué que alors qu'il est très
jeune encore une fois que c'est aussi un
militant très jeune qui ne mâche pas ses
mots parce qu'il a de la colère voilà
c'est fait attention à ce qu'on dit non
mais c'est pour ça que je pardonne et
moi je vous parle un peu gisements mais
parce que cette polémique elle commence
vraiment
oui je trouve que on mélange tout voyez
ce que j'ai en mélange tout les choses
perdre de leur de leur sens profond
hanche est sûre
la fiche de jean luc mélenchon qui a
beaucoup fait parler élisez moi premier
ministre les efforts dimanche midi c'est
pas trés sixième république cette
affiche qu'est ce que vous répondez on
aimerait bien que dans la sixième et du
coup ne pas avoir à faire ce genre d'
affiches je suis d'accord là pour le
coup je suis d'accord on aimerait on
aimerait qu'ils aient pas de
présidentielle et que du coup la
question du leader prennent moins de
place tout ça est d'accord on vous a
déjà changé cette affiche ça sera quatre
personnes si vous fermez c'est non et ce
sera toujours jean lous berretes là il
s'agit de d'abord à 105 177 en
affiche surtout mon sexe et des
législatives un docker à 570 lancé
mais jeudi à olivier faur une chose en
revanche c'est que s'il trouve que c'est
pas trés 6ème république j'espère du
coût qui sera avec nous pour défendre
une sixième république ce qui pour
l'instant n'est le dakar a priori oui
mais ce qui pour l'instant n'était pas
le cas le parti si ce n'était pas su
pour une sixième république dont je suis
ravi qu'il soit à ce moment là d'accord
pour dire avec nous que oui il faut
qu'on change d'ère et qu'on change
d'époque et pour le faire il faut jean
luc mélenchon alors premier ministre va
pas suffire parce que pour mettre en
mouvement une sixième république ça va
pas suffire il faut vraiment y ait un
président ou une présidente de la
république qui soit capable de le faire
mais on avance voilà on avance
monsieur moi je pensais surtout à un
dernier mot sur le législatif vous serez
évidemment candidate à votre propre
succession dans votre circonscription
vous êtes prête à aller c'est à un
nouveau partenaire pour l'instant dans
les accords personne ne la demandez
vous y retournez pas pourtant c'est
magnifique la conscription savourant
tremblay villepinte où jean luc
mélenchon est arrivé au total à 54% donc
voyez c'est une circonscription
effectivement que nous et je pense que
nous avons quelques raisons lui le fais
avec grand plaisir merci moquons
clémentine non merci d'être venus
nous répondre à nos questions ce matin
on regarde la une de ouest france pardon
stéphane pétrole russes vers un embargo
un embargo européen total c'est à la une
de votre journal merci vaut bien senties
noté
[Musique]